-Welcome back, everybody.
We are hanging out with
Kareem Abdul-Jabbar right here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Kareem, you're a legend
both on and off the court,
so I thought you could help me
settle some of the biggest
and most important debates ever.
-Okay.
-You ready to do this?
All right, it is time for
"Kareem Abdul-Jabbar
Settles It."
-♪ Kareem Abdul-Jabbar
settles it ♪
♪ Kareem Abdul-Jabbar
-All right. Here we go.
First up.
-Indoor because it won't rain
and you --
the sun won't beat you up.
-Yeah. There you go.
That's the game.
That's a great answer.
[ Applause ]
-Popsicles when I want to
think about learning the game
uptown when I was a kid.
And ice cream when I want to get
emotional about watching
the movie "Titanic."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-That's correct.
-Oh, geez, roller coasters.
Water slides are nothing
but outdoor bidets.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbal crashes ]
-Yeah, yeah.
You build up enough speed --
Yeah, you're right, yeah.
Oh, how about this?
This is interesting.
Ooh, I think I know the answer
to this one.
-The tears of the 1985 Celtics
when they lost to the Lakers
in the finals.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Drumroll ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
I was going to say mustard,
but --
[ Laughter ]
Oh, this one -- I think
I know the answer to this one.
-No way, man.
-Yeah. Yeah, no.
-That's like putting --
that's like putting anchovies
on Jell-O.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah, don't do that.
Let's go into movies --
summer movies.
-"Minions" because they copied
my goggles.
-Oh, yeah. That's right, yeah.
-My signature goggles.
-Your signature --
that's right.
Yeah, okay.
Good, you're right.
-I'd rather have a choice
between either of them.
[ Laughter ]
-"Star Wars." I always wanted to
play a giant monster in a movie
and for Chewbacca,
it's not going to be hard
to learn his lines.
-[ Laughs ] J.J., George Lucas,
you watching this? Come on.
-Coleslaw.
People don't want to be near me
anytime I've had a bowl
of baked beans.
[ Laughter ]
-Slam dunk if I want
to intimidate.
Skyhook if I want to show people
they can't stop me
if they tried.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And then I have to ask
you this.
Finally, once and for all...
[ Audience oohs ]
Oh, come on. You have to answer.
-No, no, no.
-You have to answer.
You have to answer.
-I'll answer.
The G.O.A.T. --
the G.O.A.T. Committee
meets in secret, okay?
[ Laughter ]
So...
That's just something we're not
going to know about, you know?
But if Lebron breaks my record
this next year coming up,
that will be one last record
that I won't have to worry about
ever again.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
But the greatest of all time?
Can I just say it?
-Why not?
-Kareem Abdul-Jabbar.
[ Cheers and applause ]
My thanks to
Kareem Abdul-Jabbar.
More information about his
charity, the Skyhook Foundation,
can be found at
kareemabduljabbar.com.
We'll be right back
with Kristen Bell.